i i look at the movies you do one after
the other and you know you go from
willy's wonderland to pig to to this and
then on to the next thing and i think
that the next thing up is the unbearable
weight of massive talent where you're
playing yourself and i'm wondering how
what it's like to jump from a shion sono
movie into something where you're
playing yourself and how you approached
you know i'm going to be playing a
version of myself after years and years
well these characters you've played that
is a really great question and i'm still
trying to answer it i'm
one of my answers is that i'm never
going to see that movie
i'm told it's a good movie
my manager mike nylon who's also a
producer on it looked at it and he was
very happy with that i'm told the
audience loves the movie
but it's just too much of a whacked out
trip for me
to go to a movie theater and watch me
play some ver tom gorman's highly
neurotic anxiety written version
because he kept pushing me in that
direction
you know i said tom you know i'm that
that's not really me i'm actually have
really quiet
you know
meditative thoughtful moments i'm not
this neurotic high strung
anxiety-ridden guy all the time but
that's he said well miranda cage is the
best cage
okay okay
so let's go man
i'll do what you want
well it's just i'm not i know i won't
see it but i do hope you enjoy it yeah
i'm really i'm really looking forward to
it